so far when i've told you about the dot
and the cross products i've given you
the definition as
the magnitudes times either the cosine
of or the sine of the angle between them
but what if you're not given the vectors
visually and what if you're not given
the angle between them how do you
calculate the dot in the cross products
so let's say let me give you the
definition that i've given you already
so let's say i have
you know a
dot b
dot product that's the magnitude of a
times the magnitude of b
times cosine of the angle between them
a cross b
is equal to the magnitude of a times the
magnitude of b
times sine of the angle between them so
kind of the perpendicular projections of
them
times the normal vector that's
perpendicular to both of the normal unit
vector and you figure out whether it's
either you know
which of the two perpendicular vector it
is by using the right hand rule but what
if we don't have them visually defined
and we don't have the thetas the the
angles between them what if for example
i were to tell you that the vector a
the vector a what if i were to give it
to you in engineering notation in
engineering notation you're essentially
just breaking down the vector into its x
y and z components
so let's say unit
vector a is
i
i is just the unit vector in the x
direction
minus
6 j
plus
k
these are all i j and k are just the
unit vectors in the x y and z directions
and the and the 5 is how much it goes in
the x direction the minus six is how
much goes in the y direction and the
three is how much it goes in the z
direction you could try to graph it and
actually i'm trying to look for a
graphing calculator that will that will
do this so i can show you all in videos
to give you more intuition but let's say
this is all you're given and let's say
that b
b
i'm just making these numbers up let's
say it's minus 2 i
and of course we're working in three
dimensions right now
plus
i don't know 7
j
plus 4 k
and you could graph them but obviously
if you were given a a problem and
actually if you're actually trying to
model uh vectors in a computer
simulation this is the way you would do
it you'd break it up into the x y and z
components because then to add vectors
you just have to add the respective
components but how do you multiply them
either taking the cross or the dot
product well it actually turns out i'm
not going to prove it here but i'll just
show you how to do it the dot product is
very easy when you have it given in this
notation actually another way of writing
this notation sometimes it's in bracket
notation sometimes they would rewrite
this as
minus 6
3 where it's just the magnitudes in the
x y and z direction just want to make
sure you're you're you're comfortable
with all of these various notations you
could write written b is -2 7 4. these
are all the same things shouldn't get
daunted if you see one or the other but
anyway so how do i take a
a dot b
this i think you'll find fairly pleasant
all you do is you multiply the i
components add that to the j components
multiplied and then add that to the k
components multiplied together so it
would be 5 times -2
so 5 times minus 2
plus
minus 6 times 7
3 times 4
plus 3 times 4. so it equals what is
this minus 10
minus
plus 12. so this is what minus 52 plus
12 so it equals
minus
40. that's it it's just a number
and i'd actually be curious to graph
this on a three-dimensional
some type of grapher to see why it's -40
they must be kind of going in opposite
directions and their projections onto
each other going to opposite directions
that's why we get a minus number and
then we you know well i you this the
purpose of this video i don't want to
get too much into the intuition this is
just how to calculate but it's fairly
straightforward you just multiply the x
components
add that to the y components multiplied
and add that to the z components
multiplied so whenever i'm given
something in engineering or bracket
notation and i have to find the dot
product it's very
almost soothing and and not not so error
prone but as you will see taking the
cross product of these two vectors when
given in this notation isn't so
straightforward and i want you to keep
in mind you know another way you could
have done it you could have figured out
the magnitude of each of these vectors
um and then you could have used some
fancy trigonometry to figure out the
thetas and then use this definition but
i i think you appreciate the fact that
this is a much simpler way of doing it
so the dot product is a lot of fun now
let's see if we can take the cross
product
and i'm not going to once again i'm not
going to prove it i'm just going to show
you how to do it in a future video
i'm sure i'll get a request to do it
eventually and i'll prove it
but the cross product this is more
involved and i never
look forward to taking the cross product
of two vectors in engineering notation a
cross b
it equals so this is an application of
matrices
so what you do is you take the
determinant
so i'll draw a big determinant line on
the top line of the determinant and this
is really just a way to make you
memorize how to do it
it doesn't give you much intuition but
the intuition is given by the actual
definition
you know how much of the vectors are
perpendicular to each other multiply
those magnitudes right hand rule figures
out what direction you're pointing in
but the way to do it
if you're given the engine orientation
you write the i j k unit vectors
in the top row i
j
k
then you write the first vector in the
cross product because order matters so
it's
5 minus 6
then you take the second vector which is
b which is minus 2
4. so you take the determinant of this 3
by 3 matrix and how do i do that well
this is equal to
that's equal to the sub determinant for
i so the sub determined for if you get
rid of this column and this row the
determinant that's left over so that's
minus 6
times i
might want to review to determine if you
don't remember how to do this but maybe
me working through it we'll just
we'll we'll
jog your memory
and then remember it's plus minus plus
so then minus
the sub determinant for j what's the sub
determinant for j well you cross out j's
row and columns you have 5 3
minus 2 4.
so 5
minus 2 4. we just crossed out j's
row and column and was never left over
those are the numbers and it's
sub-determinant
that's what i call it
j
plus i always i want to do them all in
one line because it would've been a
little bit neater plus the sub
determinant for k cross out the row and
the column for k
you have to 5 minus 6
5 minus 6
minus 2 and 7
times k
and now let's calculate them
and let me make some space because i've
written this too big
i don't think we need this anymore
so what do we get
what do we get let's take this up here
so these two by two determinants are
pretty easy this is minus six
times four
minus seven times three so it's
minus i always make careless mistakes
here minus 24 minus 21
times i
minus
5 times 4 is 20
minus minus 2 times 3 so minus
minus 6
j
it's going to do this in the next row
plus
5 times 7
minus minus 2 times minus 6 so it's
minus positive 12
k
could simplify this which equals
minus 24 minus 21 it is
minus 35 i didn't have to put the
parentheses i
and then what's 20 minus minus 6 well
that's 20 plus plus 6 so 26 and then we
have a minus out here so minus 26
j
and those 20 35 minus 12 that's 23
plus 23 k
so that's the cross product and if you
were to graph this in three dimensions
you will see and this is what's
interesting you will see that this
vector if my math is correct minus 35 i
minus 26 j plus 23k
is perpendicular to both of these
vectors
anyway i think i'll leave you there for
for now and i will see you in the next
video and hopefully i can track down a
vector graphing program because i think
it'll be fun to both calculate the dot
and the cross products using this the
methods i just showed you and then to
graph them and to show that it really
does work that this vector really is the
right hand uh it really is perpendicular
to both of these and pointing in the
direction as
you would you would predict using the
right hand rule anyway i will see you in
the next video